hello I know and welcome to this video
playing and going because rich so
Grandmaster Quaritch and what is he
doing he actually imagined supposed to
well then let me think for a moment
about this what this is opening revered
for his plagues probably some kind of e
five now he goes to the Kings Indian wow
that's usually not his repertoire so
interesting to see how it's going to
play yeah something offbeat and I think
if I've should be good just play normal
museum takes takes takes 98 96 is what
he wants to do yeah first of all I
wonder if I should go to d 3 or 2 e 2 en
disposition okay hmm first Bishop d7
here okay let me ask him this question
about the porn yeah he does not want to
play b6 this is what I expected so oh ok
so if i take this and this better for
white this position a little bit at
least no it's actually if he takes with
the bishop I have Bishop c5 and Bishop
c4 this must be trickier what's going on
here
so we should pre cross this I actually
completely completely not see that he
can play the simple move ha ok property
156 weird I did that why didn't I see
that such an easy response anyway Bishop
f8 now on what's the deal
mm okay 56 I don't know to the side and
then get AG don't get it but sampling
here so Queen d7 Bishop b5 he likes this
position really
probably have to take here not much to
do it's rather equal issue Bishop c2 why
have I have to I have to take note off
maybe just this 1i searcher I think I
missed something here somehow this look
down a little bit shaky for black I felt
it looked it looked shaky somehow check
Jim this is very draw draw our third
game draw yeah it's kind of pointless
right well why did I it screw this up I
mean isn't this somewhat better for me
when you opened it up with c6 does this
look strange I mean like not like
strange and not terrible but like I
should have something so what's going on
I took it I had a total blackout day I
was thinking I'm just winning the
exchange here which is kind of
ridiculous yeah this is probably eating
know where the engine still gives me L
or something no no no not anymore is
Bishop a fade edition web it was what I
expected but
yeah it's probably not much I said I
simply didn't see Quincy 7 which is a
bit of a blackout and it's also felt
strange but it seems to be okay looky
one is probably better Jim and the end
you'll actually find something that wins
a porn but probably probably just not
all that much check it's not so obvious
yeah okay likelihood of a draw is very
high very high can just play like 86 put
the bishop rookie aid put the bishop on
c6 this is probably be going to be a
draw it can do it can try a bit because
rooks are on the board but it's it's
probably just a draw and here simply
nothing at 10 so let's check this this
must be correct c6 so can I do somehow
improve on that the way I played I was
just really seeing ghosts they are
thinking I would win material so oh then
the engine wants to support dead
maybe it does make some sense in this
kind of position I'm not sure if the
engines ivalice is correct giving me
such a huge advantage like 0.8 it's
already quite something but and why it
should be better somewhat not sure how
much not sure how much yeah ok guys
thanks for watching this game